bonjour à tous je m'appelle florence
rivière je suis aux tris et comédienne
et en l'occurrence je suis une partie du
casting de time warp à saison 1
et si on peut faire ça votre aide saison
2 et là vous allez me dire cascades plus
cette saison 2 par rapport à la saison 1
bat déjà la plus d'épisodes
elle a plus de personnages qui aiment
davantage d'époque vous avez vu c'est
une époque sait pas vraiment plus j'ai
pas personnage de 18 forme en face on me
dise peu importe
pourquoi ta mémoire saison 1 c'était
bien
fin janvier de vous dire allez la
regarde pourquoi ta gloire saison 2
c'est encore mieux
c'est là parce que ça arrive ensuite
parce qu'il a davantage d'épisodes
ensuite parce qu'on a tous et justine la
première à prix de la saison 1 et
ensuite parce qu'il y a plein de
nouvelles époques différentes
représentées et ça c'est bien et est
ensuite parce qu'on veut abolir le
capitalisme et ça fait de nous des gens
bien des gens de qualité et c'est
pourquoi nous vous demandons votre aide
parce que nous sommes une équipe unie et
soudée qui fait face à l'adversité et
peut-être que le tournage sera annulée
deux semaines avant parce qu'il y aura
un cluster peut-être mais en attendant
et les nous habiller à manger